Back in 1965 the computer at Mit,
Cambridge cost $11 million and took up half a room.
This was the same year.
Moore's law as publishing,
claiming the computer power was doubling every 24 months.
40 years later,
the computer in your smartphone is a million times smaller,
a million times less expensive in a thousand times more powerful.
That is a billion fold increase in price performance and that trend is not
slowing down.
In fact,
it's speeding up with the next billion fold increase expected to happen within
25 years.
Well,
Kurzweil is thing is that our own biology is subject to the same effects of
Moore's law.
How much do you think you age today?
Everyone grows older but we don't all age the same.
This is why a person can look old in their thirties and young in their sixties
if you drink lots of water,
exercise,
got eight hours of sleep and had engaging in conversations with friends and
family,
you probably aged very little.
On the other hand,
if you sat on the couch,
eat donuts,
smoked and got in it,
stressful arguments,
you probably aged a lot.
When it comes to living longer,
lifestyle choices make all the difference in the world.
How long do you actually want to live?
Most people would say living longer is always going to be a good thing,
and according to Ray Kurzweil,
this is a question we're going to have to ask ourselves very soon.
He has to meets the,
if you follow his advice,
most people will be able to add an additional 20 years to their life,
but that's not it.
He says,
this extra two decades we'll allow you to live to see a new technology literally
allowing you to change your genes,
turning off bad ones and activating beneficial ones.
And this will add an additional two decades to most people's life,
which he says,
we'll give you enough time to have microscopic devices,
the size of blood cells traveling through your bloodstream and keeping you
healthy at a cellular level.
It won't be long before the sands of time run inwards rather than outwards.
Our genes are essentially little software programs and the evolved under
circumstances very different from today.
For instance,
something like the fat insulin receptor,
which says,
hold on there every calorie,
because who knows where the next meal is.
Coming from?
Something like that was very relevant from the hunter gatherer days today.
This combined with our natural inclination for cravings and overeating is what
causes an epidemic of weight problems with two and three adults being overweight
and one in three obese.
What if we could turn this gene off and turn on helpful genes?
We possess a genetic program that wants us to die young,
but what if we could eliminate things like allergies,
cancer cells,
and heart disease?
People literally won't be dying from disease and they won't be dying from old
age.
With all these things becoming incredibly possible.
The question becomes,
is this even ethical to do with so many problems like deforestation,
hunger,
and pollution caused overpopulation?
What will the effects of people literally not dying be?
If you're like Ray Kurzweil,
you probably believe the answer is more technology.
He believes no matter what difficulties we faced,
there exists an idea that can overcome it.
It is a question we will have to deal with very soon.